مرحباً بوزير الخارجية في البرنامج،
لذا هل يمكنني أولاً أن أسألك عن الصورة الكبيرة
حيث قال رئيس وزرائك إنه
يخشى أن يتم جركم إلى
حرب أوسع نطاقاً، هل
تشعرون بذلك ونخاف منه
لأن حكومة لبنان
اللبنانيون لا يريدون أي حرب
ونريد أن يكون هناك سلام في حدودنا الجنوبية
ولكن الموضوع أه تعلمون أن
ما يحدث في غزة
يؤثر بالتأكيد على ما يحدث في لبنان
لأن هناك قضايا لم
تتم تسويتها منذ 75 سنة  سنوات
ولذا لدينا مشاكل نحن بالأمس ما
حدث في لبنان هو
هجوم إسرائيلي في لبنان في بيروت أه هل سيكون هناك
رد لا أعرف إذا
كان هذا ولكن حكومة لبنان
لن تقوم بأي رد سنذهب  إلى
الأمم المتحدة وسيكون لدينا شكوى
في الأمم المتحدة، حسنًا قريبًا،
هل يمكنني أن أسألك هذا أم تعلم أن
الإسرائيليين لم يؤكدوا ذلك علنًا
ولكن أه الولايات المتحدة أخبرت شبكة CNN أنهم
يعتقدون أن هذا هو ما حدث
وأنت تعلم أن المتحدث باسم الحكومة الإسرائيلية،
مستشار رئيس الوزراء،
أشار إلى أن هذا كان
هجومًا على حماس وليس هجومًا على لبنان
وليس هجومًا على حزب الله، لذا فإن
السؤال هو هل سيستجيب لبنان أو حزب الله في
رأيك وزعيم حزب الله؟
حزب الله حسن نالا ألقى
خطابا طويلا بعد ظهر اليوم
قال فيه أساسا أه كان
عدوان إسرائيلي سافر واقتبس إذا
قرر العدو شن حرب على
لبنان فإن قتالنا لن يكون له حدود
ماذا تعتقد أنه
سيحدث آمل  وندعو ألا
يكون هناك أي رد وأن إسرائيل
لن تفعل ذلك مرة أخرى لأنه سواء
قالوا ذلك أم لا، فقد جاء في المرتبة الأولى في
أخبارهم، كما تعلمون من مختلف
القنوات التلفزيونية الإسرائيلية أنهم فعلوا ذلك
وبعد ذلك كان هناك بيان  لا تقل
ذلك، على أي حال، ما نريده هو أننا
لا نريد أي تصعيد في الحرب،
لا نريد أن يمتد ما يحدث في
الجنوب إلى لبنان،
لا نحب حرباً إقليمية لأنها
خطيرة.  إلى كل جسم خطير على
لبنان خطير على إسرائيل وعلى
الدول المحيطة بإسرائيل سواء
كانت سوريا التي أبقت على نفسها قليلاً
كحكومة خارج الحرب وسواء
أيضاً الأردن كما تعلم لأن
لديك فلسطينيين في كل مكان ولديك
أناس أه هم  أختلف أيديولوجياً
مع إسرائيل التي ستنضم
للفلسطينيين في هذه المعركة لذا فإن
الحرب الإقليمية هي سد سيء للجميع
وإذا كانت إسرائيل ستستمر في ذلك
وإذا كانت كذلك فهي إسرائيل مثل ما
حدث اليوم في إيران فهو من
صنع إسرائيلي.  إسرائيل لأنه يوجد في
العقل العربي دولتان
تستطيعان فعل ذلك إما الولايات المتحدة أو إسرائيل
وبالطبع هي إسرائيل في هذه الحالة
فإذا كان الأمر سيستمر إذا كان الأمر
سيستمر على هذا النحو أخشى أننا
أه حقًا  نقترب من حرب إقليمية
سيندم عليها الجميع في المنطقة،
هذا
رأيك في من فعل ذلك في إيران أه
يقولون إنه
هجوم إرهابي وسننتظر إذا كان
هناك أي تفاصيل أخرى أه ولكن هنا
الأمر  كلما حدث هذا أكثر، كلما
أصبحت منطقتك على المحك،
ولدينا صيحات مدعومة من إيران
تستهدف الشحن في البحر الأحمر،
ويبدو أن العام الجديد يبدأ
بتوتر أكثر وليس أقل خارج
غزة نفسها.  طوال
الفترة الماضية لعدة أشهر، كان حزب الله وإسرائيل
يتبادلان النيران والسؤال
هو فقط من وجهة نظرك، هل
يمكنك أن أعني بوضوح أنك لا تريد
كحكومة الدخول في حرب مع
إسرائيل وأنت تعلم أنني غطيت أحداث عام 2006؟  لقد
رأيت ما فعلته الحرب بلبنان
وأريد أن أعرف ما إذا كان لديك تأثير
على حزب الله، هل يمكن منعهم
من المضي قدمًا في هذا الأمر
جيدًا، لدينا دائمًا حوار ليس
مثل أه نحن نقاطع بعضنا البعض لا
نتحاور معهم رئيس الوزراء  لقد
تحدثت معه هذا الصباح وكان يتحدث
مع الحسبة طوال الوقت لا أعتقد
أنه لا أعرف أنت تعرف أن القرار
لهم ونأمل ألا يأخذوا
ولا يلزموا أنفسهم بحرب أكبر
لكننا نعمل معهم على هذا
ولدينا الكثير من الأسباب للاعتقاد
بأن
هذا لن يحدث، فنحن
لا نريد كلبنانيين جميعنا
لا نريد أي حرب لذلك أه نعم ليس الأمر كما لو أننا
نستطيع أن نأمر  نحن لا ندعي
ذلك ولكن يمكننا إقناعهم وأعتقد أنه
يعمل في هذا الاتجاه فماذا
تقول لأمريكا لأنك
ستتحاور مع أه خبراء
ومستشاري شؤون الشرق الأوسط في
مجلس الأمن القومي في  ماذا يريد البيت الأبيض
منهم بالنظر إلى حقيقة
أن الولايات المتحدة ليست الدولة الأكثر
شعبية في تلك المنطقة في الوقت الحالي، حيث
ينظر إليها الكثير من الناس على أنها مكّنت
الحرب الإسرائيلية على غزة، ويُنظر إليها أيضًا
على أنها غير قادرة على ذلك.  الكثير من
التأثير المقيد على إسرائيل، لذا
ما الذي ستطلبه من
الولايات المتحدة والذي يمكن أن يحدث
فرقًا جيدًا، فهي الدولة الوحيدة التي
يمكنها تحقيق السلام حقًا بمساعدة
دول أخرى ولكن الولايات المتحدة
هي القائد من أجل السلام  إذا كانت
تريد السلام نعم أعني أنظر عام
1975 عام 73 و 75 قبلي كان
وزير الخارجية وقد حقق
الكثير من السلام والكثير من المولى في ذلك
الوقت بسبب تأثيرهم على
إسرائيل ويمكنهم أن يفعلوا نفس الشيء إذا فعلوا ذلك
اقرأ كيسر نفسه، سيجدون
حلاً لكيفية فعل ذلك مع
إسرائيل، لكن لا يمكنك ترك إسرائيل تفعل
ما تفعله الآن لأنه ليس
عاملاً للسلام، بل عامل
لمزيد من الكراهية والمزيد من الشيء نفسه في
العالم.  المستقبل الذي نحتاجه حقًا بعد 75 عامًا
من الحرب منذ عام
1948، حان الوقت الآن لتجربة السلام، يمكننا
دائمًا الذهاب إلى الحرب إذا لم ينجح السلام،
لذلك دعونا نجرب السلام لسوء الحظ، قُتل رير
واغتيل في
19 1995، لذلك
توقفت مسيرة السلام ولكن  أعتقد أنه يجب أن
تكون هناك الآن مسيرة جديدة للسلام
الشعب الوحيد الذي يستطيع قيادتها الدولة الوحيدة
التي تستطيع قيادتها هي الولايات المتحدة
دعني أسألك سؤال آخر أه بعد
ذبح 1200 شخص داخل
إسرائيل واختطاف الآن  لا
يزال هناك حوالي 129 رهينة داخل
حماس. ردت إسرائيل
وقالت السلطات في غزة إن 22 ألف
شخص وأكثر قتلوا منذ
الهجوم الذي بدأ في 7 أكتوبر/تشرين الأول،
حسنًا، ما هو رأيك في
نتيجة ذلك في
وضع حيث  أنت تقول أنه يجب أن يكون لدينا
حل سلمي أو تسوية سلمية
بعد
هذا كما تعلم وكنت مع
البنك الدولي في أه أثناء عملية السلام في
التسعينيات وأعتقد أنني اعتقدت أن
الفلسطينيين كانوا سعداء بالحصول على السلام في
ذلك الوقت  هل يمكنني أن أشعر بهم أنهم
سعداء بالسلام
وكذلك الإسرائيليون أيضًا أه
للأسف لم ينجح الأمر كما تعلم
والآن تعلم أن 22000 يمثل 1% من
سكان غزة 1% من سكان
الولايات المتحدة  هو مثل 3.5 مليون، لذا فأنت
تعلم أن هذا كثير جدًا، وهذا ما
يجب على إسرائيل أن تفكر فيه بشأن ما يفعلونه، فهم
لا يصنعون السلام، أعني أن الأمر
ليس كذلك، حتى لو أسر جميع
قادة حماس، فسيكون هناك
قادة جدد قادمون، أعني أ  قبل بضع سنوات مضت، قبل عقدين من الزمن،
كانت هناك
قيادة مختلفة للفلسطينيين، الآن
هي حماس، ومن يدري في المستقبل
أنها ستكون كذلك طالما لم يكن هناك سلام،
وأعتقد أن المزيد والمزيد من العنف سيحدث
وما تسميه الإرهاب ماذا
ماذا  الغرب يسمي الإرهاب
والإرهابيون سيكونون عاملاً
للسلام، كان عرفات يسمى إرهابي
ميمان كان يسمى إرهابيين إرهابيين
وكذلك شعب الجيش الجمهوري الأيرلندي كان يطلق عليهم
إرهابيين ثم أصبحوا عوامل
للسلام أعتقد أن هذه هي الطريقة التي
يجب أن تعمل بها الولايات المتحدة  من
أجل تحقيق السلام أعطونا فرصة للسلام
بعد 75 سنة من الحرب أعطوا السلام
فرصة ولنرى ماذا سيحدث